Hey, listener, and welcome to Smart List. Before we get into this incredible episode, I want just a moment of your time to set the stage a little bit. Sean and Jason and I went on a smart list tour last year where we recorded 10 episodes live in front of thousands of our biggest fans from Brooklyn to Los Angeles. And guess what? Right now there are more live episodes from our tour on Wondry Plus that you can listen to. You can listen to these episodes four weeks early and add free on Wondry Plus,
after which you can hear them for free wherever you get your podcast. Find Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. All right. Welcome to SmartLess. Hey, let's do that thing really quick where we finished a sentence. We do one word at a time. No, a sentence. We do one word at a time. No, no, like we do one word like the guy. Sorry, I'll start.
Okay, we, no, ready to go. We are so excited to be here. Oh, Sean. Sean, come on, let's go. This is like what is taking a fucking road trip with you. Hey, kids, let's build a story together. Yeah. How about we just go do the Friggin Live podcast? Great.
Yeah, let's do it. All right, guys. Welcome to... ...Forgin Live Podcasts. Wow. Wow. Wow. This is so nuts. So good. Woo! This is just ridiculous. I like pulling an Oprah.
I like pulling an Oprah one free and go. Take a seat. Take a seat. I know. I know. This started. This was a big surprise. I'm going to be a big surprise. I'm going to be a big surprise. I'm going to be a big surprise. I'm pulling an Oprah. I like pulling an Oprah one free and go, take your seat.
Take your seat. Take your seat. I know, I know. This started, this is a bit. We started this as a bit. And now we're here in Brooklyn. Oh. Oh.
With all these beautiful people. I know, I love it. Thank you for coming. Thank you for spending $5 a ticket to come see us. We really appreciate it. But good God, well, they're here. I guess we got to do this. Everybody all back.
They long to sit there really low. I'm sitting there. You're going to sit there. You're going to sit there. You're going to sit in the middle. I'm going to sit in the middle. Because tonight it's my guest. So I get the middle.
Why is that good news? Yeah, why is that good news? I was good news. I will tell you I am very Excited about my guest tonight. I am my heart is pounding pounding. It's not just the diet Red Bull I am now we've all had a lot of of red bull because we had a long night. Oh my God. Oh, Jesus. So we got stuck in, where were we? Boston yesterday. Boston yesterday.
And we were, our flight was supposed to leave at 10.30 after the show. And we ended up leaving at 5 this morning, 6 this morning, something like that. 45 minute flight took us eight hours to get here. Eight hours. So we've had like three hours sleep so we're getting the best version of us. But the best part is our amazing incredible director, Sam Jones.
We're stuck on the plane and we're all kind of just really quiet. We're trying to catch any kind of winks we can. And then we hear this. Oh God, yeah. And by the way, he's like, I didn't get any sleep. We're like, no, no, no, you're the only one who got sleep. Yeah. None of us.
And then we get to the hotel. They always make fun of me because I always have my kind of my things. Like when you travel, you have your things. And so I always ask for a fan and a blanket. I need an extra fan. So every time we pull into it. And listen to that gloss over.
Listen to that gloss over. Every time we pull into a hotel, Sean, there's always a 20 minutes later, there's a knock on the door. And a guy shows up with a fan and a big blanket. And we're like, no, wrong room. And then Sean shoots up. No, no, no, there's a knock on the door, and a guy shows up with a fan and a big blanket. Like, yeah. And we're like, no, wrong room. And then Sean shoots up, no, no, that's me. Because we're all staying together. Do we mention that?
We're staying the same room? We're all in the same room. It's all for the stupid ass show. Where do you see it? It's such a mistake. Actually, it should be noted, you wanted to stay in the same room. Well, I thought it was like,
well, if we're gonna do it, let's get full stupid ass. Yeah. So Jason's like, nothing, we're all gonna stay together and we're all just gonna be in, we can just 24 hour access to the cameras, six hours into it, he's like, fuck this. Yeah. It's a nightmare.
You're a nightmare. Because I'm not usually, this is, I'm peaking right now. I'm usually in such a bad mood. Am I not a moody guy? Yeah, you're very, very moody guy. Every morning, this coming straight at me, just his hair is about eight feet high with the bed head, with the cup of coffee,
so fucking angry, he's coming right at me. And he shuffles, too. You know how he shuffles? He walks like this. No, I'm not exaggerating. He walks like this, and he looks like, you look like all of his bones are so kind of like, he walks like this. No, I'm not exaggerating. He walks like this, and he looks like, he looks like all of his bones are so brittle,
like he's about to snap. Ha ha ha ha. But guess, is that true? It's true, it's true. Daddy's back hurts. Yeah, no. A lot. Um, what else?
I don't know. What else? So much else. Should we just get to the guest? Yeah, let's get to the guest. I mean, we got him with? So much else. Should we just get to the guest? Yeah, let's get to the guest. I mean, we gone with it. All right. Your guest.
All right, Granddad needs notes, too. Gang dash. We've been going to different cities, and in each city, we are trying to invite a guest that is part of its fabric, its spirit, its soul. This guy, so now you know it's a man, checks the boxes, he is also... Julianne...
Uh-oh. ...un... ... ... Julianne. Wait, no, I say... Don't turn them against us already. Wait, I may have skipped a sentence hold on a second Gang dash
We've been going to different cities and in each city we're trying to invite a guest that is part of its fabric It's spirited soul this guy checks those boxes. He's also an enormous hero to each of us. Oh He is comedy royalty. I know exactly who it is. Oh, shit, you don't know this thing. I know exactly. Don't guess it yet. Hold on. Mouth it to me.
Hold on. Don't let me see it. And he is the undisputed best at what he does. Right? There's no- Keeps going like this. Martin Short. Martin Short.
Short. Are Short. Short. Are you finished? Sorry. Dang, dash. Fuck. Thank you, Sean. All right. He's the undisputed best at what he does. No one better.
Period. He has 52 Emmy nominations to prove it. Along with 12 wins. He's got a Kennedy Center Honor, a Mark Twain Award, but in the last few years he has selflessly chosen to stop everything and fill in for the recently deceased Santa applause. Will, Sean, Brooklyn, please welcome Mr. David Letterman. No! No! Come on, Dave. No! Thank you. Oh, no. Oh! Whoa!
Hi, Sean. Where's Pleasure to see you. Jason? Where's Pleasure to see you. Where? All my best, my friend. Nice to see you Jason. We're pleasure to see you. We're all my best my friend. Oh my gosh Thank you very much Hi, yeah, wow Thank you. What a what a lovely thing and what a beautiful theater and thank you and thank you again. That was delightful. I was, uh, holy shit, right?
Yeah. I'm sitting backstage listening to you guys. Thinking about the mistake you made. No, and I'm all I can think of is I hope this doesn't cut into my time. Yeah, sorry. We have run a little long. Let me get to question eight. Oh my gosh. Oh, this is key. Great. First of all, before you get into the question,
go well. It's so great to see you. Thank you for inviting me, please. Yeah. It is. Yeah. At risk of embarrassing you, I should say that, and I think I speak for Sean, but it is such an honor
to have you here. You have always truly been one of my friends. Oh, please. I know. And I've done your so many, and I've told you that before, but it's true, and I'm so delighted that you're here. Oh, God bless all of you. I would just like to add that he said he'd speak for me,
but I've never said anything like that. Oh, let me, I have a rundown. I have my own sort of document on you guys. My dossier here, when you were first on the show, what I remember about you, I think you were smoking. Yes. Yeah, you really? Yeah, I think you were.
No, I was going in and out of smoking, and you would check in on my various appearances as to whether or not I was smoking at the time. You didn't smoke on the show, though. No, I never smoked on it, but I did do, you liked when I went through my various smoking positions. Yes, yes. Which were, I told you I'd quit, but I missed doing the, like, me?
Yeah, yeah, sure. Like that kind of stuff. Yeah, I mean, that was the hook upon which you were booked. Yes. Yeah. I did it. And extremely funny and Toronto. I remember that about you.
Yes, thank you. Thank you. Now, yeah. And Sean, the last few times you were on the show, you were doing a musical across the... Promises. Promises hold for applause. Yeah. CHEERING AND APPLAUSE
And I don't know if it was between shows or before the show, but you came on with such inviable energy, such good natured, likable excellence as a human. That's the Coke. Yeah, very. And... LAUGHTER Whenever we would be talking after the show, as a human. That's the Coke. Yeah. And... Ha-ha-ha! Whenever we would be talking after the show,
the comment was always, why does it Sean have his own show? Well, like a talk show. I know you've had shows. Right? I mean, that would be fantastic. You thought about it? Yes, I thought about it.
It's very kind of you. And if I ever did it, here we go, you are one of the? Yes, I thought about it. It's very kind of you. And if I ever did it, here we go, you are one of the biggest reasons why I would do it. The biggest. Yeah, you are such a huge influence on me. And so many people, I know you hate that. You're like, where do I put it? No.
But it's like, it's really, really true you are what makes sense. Thank you. I really appreciate the opening of the hero of all of our show. Thank you. Thank you. Now, I'm here, and I'm not gonna get to you. Now you are on the show of Our Foreshirt. Thank you. Now, here, now I'll get to you. Now you are on the show many, many, many times. And I know you were believed in what we had pre-show meetings.
And it was not with me. No, not with you. Everyone was very excited. And then you would come on and be let down. Wow, can the guy talk? And I mean, really, we only had an hour show. And then he was so, he had so many stories. And he told them so well, and he had the memorized beat.
It was like talking to Charles Dickens for God's sake. And then at 10.45, the people would be in the broadcast center, at center, editing, because he had gone so long. So that's what I remember about the appearances of the three of you. You were in a blackout, weren't you, most of the time? I've been a blackout right now.
Now, this is a fascinating to hear you say this, because I've always wanted to ask you this, or anyone that I have been on a talk show with. Because, so, for those, there are for Tracy. Um, Tracy. Tracy. Tracy. Tracy, yeah.
John's sister is Wisconsin. John's sister in Wisconsin doesn't understand. Showbiz Lingo. Sometimes we got a filler in on the inside baseball. So, there is a pre-interview that a guest usually does, so that in the absence of a conversational skill, you have a set of predetermined questions and ballpark answers so that the host and the guest can have a palatable interview. Non-existent on this show.
Non-existent. That's not what I was talking about. No, it's not what I was talking about. No, it's not what I was talking about. No, it's not what I was talking about. No, it's not what I was talking about. No, it's not what I was talking about. It's not what I was talking about.
It's not what I was talking about. It's not what I was talking about. It's not what I was talking about. It's not what I was talking about. It's not what I was talking about. It's not what I was talking about. So now I, because I like all of us in this room and across the planet are a huge fan of Dave Letterman, you wanna make sure you got your stuff together. So I'd work on what could I possibly do, what's funny that's happened in my life in the last few weeks? So I've got some stuff to say.
He's doing it now. Yes. So I would have these stories and I thought I'm being responsible say. He's doing it now. Yes. Yes. So I would have these stories, and I thought I'm being responsible, because by the way, I remember watching you do an interview, maybe it was 60 minutes or something, where they would say to you, what constitutes a good interview,
and you said, and I never forgot it, it drives you nuts when people come on the show, and they think that you are lucky to have them sitting in the chair when, in fact, they're lucky to sit in the chair because they're trying to promote something. Yeah, I mean, we're really, I don't know. I just got a cue from the stage.
So I always wondered if I went on too long and now he's telling me I did all those years. They all know, they listen to the podcast so they know you go on too long and Dave knows you go on too long, but we all love you, Jason. Yes, we do. What?
Now you also, some of your colleagues visit with a guest before they come out. You never did that one. I would never do that. No. I love that. So there was a question 10, 15 minutes ago, you're going to go down and say hi to Dave. I was like, well, no, he never did that with any of his guests. I think that's why I probably shouldn't.
No, I would put a good decision. Yes, it was absolutely in my case. I can't speak for the world, but in my case, that was a good decision. Why? Because you're down, so 10 minutes ago, you're down and dressing, what are you doing? Everything I know about, well, that's none of your business.
But everything I know about running a talk show, I learned from Johnny Carson. And Johnny Carson... He never came back. He was the guy before Jay Leno. Jay would come back into the room, but Johnny... Yeah, I understand it was like the Rotary Club with Jay. But Johnny would never come down,
because he always felt like, whether I know the guest or do not know the guest, I want oh hi welcome to the house moment and that initial electricity or lack thereof should should come naturally that's the point that's the point of the whole show can I ask you this what was your do you I'm sure you remember what was your your first meeting like with Johnny what was that event was that because he was hiring you to do the show? What was that, Paul? What was that, Paul?
Or was that a regular appearance? Yeah, the first time I was on the tonight show as a guest. And it's interesting because we're talking about Johnny Carson. Had we been talking about Johnny Carson 30 years ago, the room would be full of a different kind of electricity. Sure, yeah. But for those who didn't experience that, he was, I think, the best ever at the show business,
late night, television, and so on, so formal. With that question. And if you look at what he did now, the consistency of what this guy did. I mean, it wasn't once a week. It was night after night after night. I will watch reruns with my husband. I'm gay, Dave.
I would watch... Still? Yeah, still. Yeah. I am taking every medication. It's not working. Okay. Oh, my God.
This is awful. I know it's an awful... We need stuff to cut, Dave. So, Dave, I would... Me and Scotty, a lot of times, check out old Johnny Carson episodes. And it's amazing how long he spoke to the guest. It was like a 20 minute, 30 minute interview.
And are you happy that you didn't have to do that? Or would you have preferred to have the time? Well, that's an excellent question. I think you always would like a little more time, especially if you're enjoying the moment, the guest. But the thing about Johnny, he just was always Johnny, and it didn't make any difference who the guest was, or what was going on. You just wanted a chance before you went to sleep to visit with your friend, Johnny. And he did that for 30 some years.
And there was, I never saw the guy break a sweat. I never saw him miss a beat. But people feel the exact same way about you. How you do? Well, how many, how many, like to see the paperwork on this? How many, and we're going to get into Jason's appearance on Johnny Carson, his first one.
Oh, yeah, there you go. There you go. It's great. And I wish we had an image we could pull up, because it's tremendous. This is great. But how many times did you do the tonight show with Johnny, before you then he sort of anointed you as the,
you know, to do the late night? Well, you guest hosted a bunch, yeah? Yep, a few times, maybe a couple of dozen times a guest hosting and appearing as a guest on the show. And then we got the 1230 show, which Seth Meyers now has, and Conan O'Brien had that show for a while as well. I wanna tell you something,
I've been listening to the show. And yes, and I had it on when Ryan Reynolds was on. God bless Ryan Reynolds. And a great Canadian. And I started thinking, oh, this is, I have to talk to him for the little Netflix deal. And I listened to him on your show, and I thought there's no point.
This is the best piece of entertainment, not in a film with Ryan Reynolds and friends. I just, it depressed me. So today, I thought, okay, I'm gonna be there in Brooklyn and I'll just listen to another one. And it was very son and child. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh right, I know, and he was on your show a lot. Yes, he was. And we love to talk about a guy that had to have a little editing. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. They were still working on his last segment. You know the story about his getting,
when he's first started in pornography as a young cameraman. And that story, which was about five minutes at our show, was 40 minutes. And we all agreed that even for us, we thought there's no way. My mom can't hear this story. We pulled it out, and we'll ever hear it.
It's the most repulsive story. It is repulsive. You can ever imagine it's really. We rarely do that. So the same thing with this, I know Barry Sonnetfeld, as Will mentioned, and I couldn't finish listening it because it was so good and I thought, oh, I'm going to go out there and just dump all over their show.
And I tell you what I love about it is the theme music for the podcast. It's great. It's catchy. They haven't put the bar too high. No, no. It's great. You know the show can live up to that.
Yeah. And then the very son of a film, when you were in London. Yes. And I'm thinking this is the example of why radio ruled the world before television. Instantly now, I'm envisioning myself being in London and you guys I assume were on the West Coast. Yeah, yeah. Didn't really come to mind.
In slippers. In slippers. In PJs, but I just I was delighted by it, but then again the interview with Barry Sanovel was so good I couldn't finish that one either. I'm sorry now are you are you are you love are you loving doing long-form Conversations as opposed to the the 10 minute sprints well. There's two different things here Yes, the longer the better but but but you know, they's two different things here. Yes, the longer the better, but you know, they're two different machines. The talk show is understanding he had trouble on the airplane coming in from LA. That's the talk show. Yeah And then the longer form is have you ever seen an airplane? That's that's a whole different story
It's a little roomier in that house. And we will be right back. SmartLess is supported by rocket money. Have you ever rediscovered a subscription you forgot about and had been paying for months? I have, and I can't say what it is because I don't want to get in trouble. I just found out like a couple months ago, I've been paying for something and I can't say what it is, because I don't want to get in trouble. I just found out like a couple months ago, I've been paying for something that I didn't know I was getting, or not getting for that matter.
Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend around 80 bucks a month on subscriptions, but the actual total is closer to $200. If you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, you need rocket money. Rocket money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions, monitors you're spending, and helps you lower your bills all in one place. Over 80% of people have subscriptions they forgot about, and chances are, you're one of them,
like me. Like that streaming service app, just to watch one show or that free gaming trial you never actually used. Rocket money will quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you and for any you don't want to pay for anymore. Just hit cancel and Rocket money will cancel it for you. It's that easy. Rocket money also helps you manage all your finances in one place and automatically categorize
your expenses so you can easily track your budget in real time and also get alerted if anything looks off. Over 3 million people have used Rocket Money, saving the average person up to 720 bucks a year. Stop throwing your money away, cancel unwanted subscriptions, and manage your expenses the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com slash smartless.
That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocketmoney.com slash smartless. I'm Rex Chapman and these days most people know me for trolling weirdos on the internet, which is fun, but believe it or not I had a whole career before that playing basketball in the NBA. I played for four teams over 12 years in the league alongside so many incredible players. But no matter where I went, there was one guy on every team who was totally untouchable. That was the owner. Plenty of fans don't even know who owns their team, who's making the backroom deals and
moving players around like pieces on a game board. But every week on owned, we're to take the fancy elevator sneak pass security and find out what it means to be a power player in the big leagues of pro sports. Now I said, I keep giving the money, but they keep getting the same result. The family is like the wealthy but un-sixie Kardashians. Follow OND wherever you get your podcast. You can listen early and add free on the Amazon music or one DRIAP.
All right, back to the show. When you decide who you want to talk to, or you, because like for us, it's obviously it's see if hero x, y, or z is interested in talking to us. And, or who could we learn something from because we are less than smart? That's true. How do you go about deciding who you want to be? It's the same.
Everything is a compromise. And sometimes you're pleased with a compromise. Sometimes you have to take one and wait your turn. It's not, that's the most difficult part about it. I'm guessing you gentlemen perhaps do not have the obstacles that we sometimes have getting guests for our show. Because hang on. No, no.
I want to say, everybody I knew when they, because people, they're surprised to see me. They say, well, what are you going to do? And I mentioned this, oh my goodness. Yeah. For some reason, people really embrace the idea of the show. I don't get it. That's oh my goodness. For some reason people really embrace the idea of the film. I don't get it. That's a good point for some reason. That's the part of this success. It's so beautiful because it's so organic because I believe you are friends
from a previous existence. Yes, we're three. And we did start it genuinely so that we could spend time with each other. And it came in a COVID before the pandemic. And that was quite legitimate. And we did set the bar very low. It was very DIY. And it's still, for all intents and purposes, is the way we do the show, the way we put it together. Do it myself. Do it myself.
Thank you. And we, and we, we, we, we try to keep resetting the bar as low as possible. And that's where I wish I could go back and tell my parents in high school how important it was to keep the bar low. That's what I was building to this, you know what I mean? It's like being in the admiral's club waiting for a flight
and you hear three people genuinely interesting and friendly talking to one another. But you had ratings to tell you, oh, there are people watching. We literally opened up our laptops again, and our pajamas doing this, had no idea if people were listening to this. And then you nice people bought tickets to a tour,
which was the only verification we had that people were listening. It's a little absurd. Thank you very much. It is absurd. Dave, I, you know. Oh, it's absurd. Hold it over the side.
This is great. You really, really wanted the man. It's not, you know, everybody. Let me help you out, favorite color. You know, Dave, I don't know if you know that Sean was nominated. For a host of the year. Oh, host of the year.
Host of the year. I, I heart radio podcast, host of the year. Oh, host of the year. Host of the year, I heart radio podcast, host of the year. And again, I'm not to belabor it, but Sean sent Jason in the text saying, hey guys, congrats, we were nominated for this award and the second sentence highlights the fact that he was nominated for a host of the year. To which Jason I was appointed,
well congrats, I guess. Yeah, he didn't read for host of the year. To which Jason I was put in, well, congrats, I guess. Yes. He didn't read the body of the email, just the headline that we got in a couple of nominees. Well, on the most joyous part of that whole thing was you losing. That's right. You lost.
Who wins host of the year? Who is host of the year? No idea. No, no, no, seriously. Who won? I'm being serious. I have no idea. How do you earn nominee?
You should know. Yeah. You've been nominated. You know all the people in here, I can't. I sure. I should. I should. Throw a pin up on your wallet.
Yes. And most of them are John Stewart. I swear. You do. You know, the grind of a talk show that you, the late night of the day of the letterman, everybody knows the grind is just, you work your balls off, like five days a week, you're always there,
everybody knows that, and because of that, you tend to have a more reclusive life, and we all, people are kind of amazed when you appear anywhere, because it's like, oh my god, it's like a magic trick. It's like somebody pulled you into these accusations that you're a reckless. Right?
Oh my god, he's walking upright. But so what do you think has changed since your show? You chose to end your show from then and now have you evolved into other than your Netflix, other than business wise, what do you reflect upon now and think differently about? Your Honor, could I hear the question again, please? Is that what I sound like? Oh, no, that was not even close to what it was better.
That was worse than that. That was Reader's Digest compared to you. Well, I could have started. While you're answering, I'm going to start studying my question. I don't know exactly what to say. Yes, that's OK. That's OK. I just think like, are you more open to things
that you weren't now that you may have not been? Well, I realize that, and perhaps the three of you feel the same, and I hope not, when you have a show, and I don't know that it's like that now, but I was so single-minded that I shut out a lot of other experiences in my life that I should have been enjoying. Well, this is what I'm talking about, David.
Well, I wish you had said that. Easy. We're just not pressing them. Why are you making this so contentious? If you want to lay down for the rest of the therapy, I can go sit over there. But I will say that many, many things that are more important to me now than I knew they were when I had a show.
And I think that's lopsided. So that's a regret of being on the air that long ago. I feel like we're scurrying around family. Let's talk about family, Dave. OK. No, let's talk about your family. What about your sister? Thank you.
Sheeran, she's going to come to Madison. I love Binda Madison, University of Wisconsin. Beautiful. Yeah. Yeah, we're going there. Yeah, I'm going to say we're going there. Yeah, that's the same. Now, I used to love you talking about your drive to work in your monologue.
希兰，她要来麦迪逊。我爱宾达·麦迪逊，威斯康星大学。太美了。对。对，我们要去那儿。对，我要说我们要去那儿。对，都一样。以前我挺喜欢听你在独白里聊你开车上班的事的。
Did you drive here today? I rode here. You rode here today. Did you? We sent a car? Someone did. OK. Now, do you?
你今天开车来的吗？我骑车来的。你今天骑车来的。是吗？我们派了车吗？有人派了。好吧。现在，你吗？
What will? I'm sorry. I thought you meant a motorcycle. I legitimately did. I wish. Oh, you know how I got here? Am I Harley? You know, you got motorcycles.
什么会？对不起。我还以为你说的是摩托车。我真的这么以为。真希望是。哦，你知道我是怎么来的吗？骑着我的哈雷？你知道的，你有摩托车。
And I wish it was a door. I came on my motorcycle. My Harley, Davidson, today. That's not true. No. No, no. You've got some. You've got some.
我倒希望是个门。我今天骑着我的摩托车来的。我的哈雷戴维森。这不是真的。不。不，不。你有一些。你有一些。
Yeah, but when you get to be my age, every time you get on when you think, oh, I shouldn't be on this. Right. And so they are less written than they get to be my age, you every time you get on when you think, oh, I shouldn't be on this. Right. And so they are less written than they used to be. Do you still like driving fast? Yes, I do, but I don't anymore. I lost my license for a month because of driving fast,
对，但到了我这个年龄，每次你骑上去的时候，你都会想，哦，我不该骑这个。对。所以它们比以前少写了，你到了我这个年龄，每次你骑上去的时候，你都会想，哦，我不该骑这个。对。所以它们比以前少写了。你还喜欢开快车吗？是的，我喜欢，但我现在不开了。我因为开快车被吊销了一个月的驾照，
and that took it right out of me. Because... On the merit. On the merit part of the race. Yeah, that is yeah, that's a great road to drive quickly on What what what how fast hands of Connecticut highways hey, yeah How fast where we going? The fastest I've gone in a passenger car. There's two figures. There's the European number and then there's the Long Island
这直接把我那股劲给吓没了。因为……在那个赛事上。在那个比赛的名次上。对，那是，对，那是一条开快车的好路。什么，什么，康涅狄格州的高速公路限速多少，嘿，对。多快？我们在哪儿开的？我在乘用车里开过的最高时速。有两个数字。一个是欧洲数字，另一个是长岛
Expressway number. Long Island Expressway 140. Yeah, that's Christmas. Autobahn 150. Nice. Wow. Nice. Now, don't you agree with me?
高速公路的数字。长岛高速公路，140英里。对，那是克里斯马斯。德国高速公路，150英里。不错。哇。不错。现在，你难道不同意我的看法吗？
Nice. Don't you like it a lot. I think that makes a lot of sense, right? So there's no sense. Jason Lemme. No, Jason, you're a very...? So there's no scene, Lemon. Jason, no, Jason, no, Jason, tell him, you're a very, Jason has won the... Well, please, yes, I said,
不错。难道你不觉得很好吗？我觉得这很有意义，对吧？所以毫无意义。杰森，等等。不，杰森，你是一个非常……？所以没有现场，莱蒙。杰森，不，杰森，不，杰森，告诉他，你是一个非常，杰森赢得了……好吧，拜尔，是的，我说，
cheesy celebrity race. You won the... Oh, the Toyota celebrity, Ron, great. But you did that, didn't you? I never did it because I knew I would make a fool of myself. Oh, I bet you would. But you won the race? I did pretty well.
无聊的名人赛。你赢得了……哦，丰田名人赛，太棒了。但你参加过，不是吗？我从来没参加过，因为我知道我会出丑。哦，我敢说你会的。但你赢了那场比赛？我表现得挺好。
He, first, one year, second and third. I don't like to brag. Wow. So you were on the podium three years in a row? I don't know if they were consecutive. Yeah, I know. But I'm fine. And Jason, you're not going to switch the subject.
他，第一年第一，第二，第三。我可不喜欢吹牛。哇。所以你连续三年登上领奖台了？我不知道它们是不是连续的。对，我知道。但我很好。杰森，你可别想转移话题。
And in a non-salebredy race, you also partook in a professional race in the polcanoes, am I right? Yes, we did a lime rock. A lime rock. And then the polka nose, am I right? I, yes, we did a lot, lime rock and then the polka nose, I got in a spill because some dingbat, got in a crash in front and then I had to go through the wreckage, flipped over and the wheel well came up, the wheel came up through the wheel well, smashed my ankle, broke a bone,
在一场非名人赛中，你还参加过波科诺的职业比赛，我没说错吧？是的，我们在莱姆罗克。莱姆罗克。然后是波科诺，我没说错吧？我，是的，我们去了很多地方，莱姆罗克，然后是波科诺，我出了个事故，因为某个笨蛋在前面撞车了，然后我不得不冲过残骸，车翻了，轮拱翘了起来，轮子从轮拱里钻了出来，砸碎了我的脚踝，骨折了，
only broke a bone I've ever had. And then I said, I'm gonna leave this to the professionals, I'll go back to the cheesy stuff. Well, he illustrates exactly what kept me from doing this sort of thing. He's exactly right. Now, were you on the oval at Pocano? Um, the tri oval. The tri oval? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
这是我唯一一次骨折。然后我说，我还是把这留给专业人士吧，我回去搞那些无聊的东西。好吧，他完美地说明了是什么阻止了我去做这种事。他说得太对了。现在，你在波科诺的椭圆赛道上了吗？嗯，三叶形椭圆赛道。三叶形椭圆赛道？对，对，对，对。
Um, that you can get some speed going there. But, uh, it's speaking of speed, don't you? What kind of car were you in? This was a Sport Truck series, so it's pick-up trucks, but lowered. It's not, yeah, see, it's not that impressive. There is nothing. Right? Nothing impressive.
嗯，你在那里能开出很高的速度。但是，呃，说到速度，难道你不？你开的是什么车？这是运动卡车系列，所以是皮卡，不过是降低了底盘的。这不，是的，你看，这没那么让人印象深刻。没有什么。对吧？没什么印象深刻的。
Nothing. More exciting than watching trucks. Oh, where do I get my season pass? So, from the excitement of car racing to something truly mundane, I really want to know, what'd you do today? What do you do every day? Now that's what I'm interested in. I want to know what's just a normal day for Dave.
没有。比看卡车更让人兴奋的了。哦，我在哪儿能买到季票？所以，从赛车的刺激转向真正世俗的事情，我真的很想知道，你今天做了什么？你每天都做什么？这正是我感兴趣的。我想知道戴夫的日常生活是怎样的。
Are you an early riser? Let's start there. Not an early riser. I go to bed late. I stay up late watching climbing movies. Oh, no, no, shut up. Wait a minute. Will, oh God.
你是个早起的人吗？我们从这开始。不是早起的人。我睡得很晚。我熬夜看攀岩电影。哦，不，不，闭嘴。等一下。威尔，哦天哪。
He loves, he loves, any of the foreign crime shows on Netflix with subtitles. He'll talk to your ears bleed about that or climbing stuff. Yeah, but wait, what about solo? Did you see solo? Free solo. Free solo. This is years ago for me. Han Solo. No, no, no, see solo? Free solo. Free solo. This is years ago for me.
他喜欢，他喜欢Netflix上所有带字幕的外国犯罪剧。他会跟你聊个没完，直到你耳朵流血，或者聊攀岩之类的东西。对，但是等等，单人登顶呢？你看到单人登顶了吗？徒手攀岩。徒手攀岩。对我来说这是好几年前的事了。韩·索罗。不，不，不，看单人攀岩？徒手攀岩。徒手攀岩。对我来说这是好几年前的事了。
Han Solo. No, no, no. Free solo. I'm down to watching Salavaki and people climb their way through the Tatras in English subtitled. And I don't know why. I know Alex Hanel, like he's a member of the family. Yeah, sure. And I can't stop watching.
韩·索罗。不，不，不。徒手攀岩。我落魄到看斯洛伐克语以及人们在英语字幕下艰难通过塔特拉山的视频。我不知道为什么。我知道亚历克斯·霍诺德，就像他是家庭成员一样。对，当然。而且我停不下来看。
That's the free solo guy. Yeah, he's amazing. I know he's been on of the family. And I can't stop watching. That's the free solo guy, Alex. Yeah, he's amazing. I know he's been on the show, eh? Hey, no, he's the Canadian. That's the Canadian. Sorry. Now, there's something about Mal. But he should be on the show.
那是徒手攀岩的那个人。Yeah，他太棒了。我知道他一直都是家庭成员。我停不下来看。那是徒手攀岩的那个人，亚历克斯。对，他太棒了。我知道他上过节目，对吧？嘿，不，他是加拿大人。那是加拿大人。抱歉。现在，马尔有些地方。但他应该上节目的。
He should be on the show. And the 100-foot wave, too. Sorry, just that's incredible. Of course, yeah. Anytime you see these people who are doing incredible things, and the other guy who was 14- just that's incredible. I mean, any time you see these people who are doing incredible things, and the other guy who, yeah, 14-pick. Excellent, yeah.
他应该上节目。还有百尺浪，也是。抱歉，那个太不可思议了。当然，是的。每当你看到这些人做着不可思议的事情，还有另一个14岁的——太不可思议了。我是说，每当你看到这些人做着不可思议的事情，而另一个人，是的，14岁选的。太棒了，是的。
And we're good. And, no, there is something about Mount Everest. Did you get heckled a lot last night with the business? Yeah, well, we did. I mean, if, if, you know, the sound of seats emptying, counts as heckling, I'm sure. Forgive me.
我们很好。而且，不，关于珠穆朗玛峰确实有些特别之处。昨晚你的演出被那些家伙起哄得很厉害吗？对，嗯，我们确实遇到了。我是说，如果，如果，你知道的，座位空掉的声音算作起哄的话，那肯定是。请原谅。
Can't wait there were quite a few people that left. Let's go, Carol. It's your first, Ellen. There is something about Mount Everest that's like a magical draw to me. Do you have a Mount Everest draw at all? Well, I know quite a lot about Mount Everest from the two dozen films I've watched
简直不敢相信有那么多人离开。我们走吧，卡罗尔。这是你的第一次，艾伦。关于珠穆朗玛峰，有一种神奇的吸引力吸引着我。你对珠穆朗玛峰有什么吸引力吗？嗯，我对珠穆朗玛峰了解很多，因为我看了两打关于攀登珠穆朗玛峰的电影。
about climbing Mount Everest. Would two dozen films I've watched about climbing Mount Everest. Would you? Oh, God no. Really? What do you like about what's fat? I don't know. Yeah.
两打我看的关于攀登珠穆朗玛峰的电影。你会吗？哦，天哪，不。真的吗？你喜欢什么？我不知道。对。
I just don't know. Somebody's seeing a challenge through like that kind of a hefty lift. Yes, the scenery, typically lovely. And the kind of things I will not see probably in my lifetime regrettably. Yeah, I felt that way like when I went to Paris for the first time. I was like, well, there's a full tower.
我只是不知道。有人能坚持完成这样一个挑战，感觉就像是一次艰巨的壮举。是的，风景通常很迷人。而且这些可能是我有生之年遗憾地看不到的景象。对，我有这种感觉就像我第一次去巴黎的时候。我就想，哦，那就是埃菲尔铁塔。
It's just like every movie and post-credits. I got it. I'm ready to go. Well, when you're climbing Mount Everest, every film about climbing Mount Everest, I'm sorry, did I lean on your laughter? No. It wasn't going to get higher. So you would not, what about your base camp? No, no, good Lord, no. It's just a helicopter ride.
它就像每部电影和片尾彩蛋里的一样。我懂了。我准备好了。嗯，当你攀登珠穆朗玛峰时，每一部关于攀登珠穆朗玛峰的电影，抱歉，我是不是靠在你笑的声音上了？不。它不会更高了。所以你不会，那你的大本营呢？不，不，天哪，不。那只是坐直升机。
No, it's not. Helicopter's can't fly above 20,000 feet. Because the air is so thin. No, no, no, but they do rescues that are higher than that, right? No. No. No.
不，不是的。直升机不能飞到两万英尺以上。因为空气太稀薄了。不，不，不，但他们做过比那更高的救援，对吧？不。不。不。
God. Rescue's above that elevation are rarely successful. But you get into what they call the depth zone. The depth zone, yeah. Where your body starts consuming itself. Yeah. And the air is so thin and you lose your voice, and you get dizzy, and you get blockheaded.
天哪。那个高度以上的救援很少能成功。但你会进入他们所说的死亡区。死亡区，是的。你的身体开始自我消耗的地方。对。空气是那么稀薄，你失去了声音，你感到头晕，你变得脑子糊涂。
And I heard one man describe, he was was coughing up tissue from his own throat. Oh. So you see why I can't live without him. LAUGHTER David. That's great. Now, you don't do climbing either. I don't do climbing either.
我听到一个人描述，他咳出了自己喉咙里的组织。哦。所以你看为什么我不能没有他。笑声大卫。太棒了。现在，你也不攀岩。我也不攀岩。
My dad climbed Kilimanjaro when he was about 73. Wow. Which is not huge, yeah. But it's a big deal. But it's pretty big. Nineteen thousand feet. And what? Yeah. I always tell these guys stuff about my dad
我爸爸大约73岁时登顶了乞力马扎罗。哇。虽然不是极高，对。但这是一件大事。但相当大。一万九千英尺。然后呢？对。我总是跟这些家伙说我爸爸的事，
and they're like, what? And I'm like, well, you never, you guess, and it turns out they never ask. Yeah. Well, kill me. They wrote a book during quarantine. He wrote a note. Yeah, you board us with earlier.
而他们就说，什么？我就说，好吧，你们从来不，你猜，结果他们从来不问。对。好吧，杀了我。他们在隔离期间写了一本书。他写了一本笔记。对，你之前用这个烦过我们。
Yeah. And fiction. And fiction. A fiction, but based on a true story. You guys never ask about my dad. Well... It's not a happy story. How do you describe a black hole?
对。还有小说。还有小说。一本小说，但基于真实故事。你们从来不问我关于我爸的事。好吧……这不是一个快乐的故事。你怎么形容一个黑洞？
Like, you know what I mean? Well, it's just a just a tire screeching. Speaking of speeding away, yeah. And we don't mean it. Sean, he invites this day, by the way. Just in case you think we're being cruel, he set me up for that. I feel like I came on a bad night.
就像，你知道我的意思吗？好吧，这只是一声刺耳的轮胎摩擦声。说到开车溜走，是的。我们不是那个意思。肖恩，顺便说一句，是他邀请我来这一天的。以防你们觉得我们很残忍，是他给我设了个套。我觉得我挑了个糟糕的夜晚来。
I know you did come on a bad night. I wanted to ask you just to get out of climbing for a second and go back to just, because I'm fascinated with when you started doing late night. And in fact, I think you, and correct me if I'm wrong, started actually in a daytime show in the hosting capacity. I used to watch it all the time.
我知道你确实挑了个糟糕的夜晚。我想问你，先别聊攀岩了，回到……因为我对你什么时候开始做深夜脱口秀很着迷。事实上，我认为你——如果我记错了请纠正我——其实是从主持一档白天节目开始的。我以前经常看。
It was on NBC at like nine in the morning. Yes, I used to watch it as a kid. I was fascinated by you. Because nobody was doing that kind of comedy, especially in the day and the morning. But you started and that you got that job coming out of you were a standup for many years. And what was that transition like?
它在NBC早上九点左右播出。是的，我小时候经常看。我对你很着迷。因为没有人做那种喜剧，特别是在白天和早晨。但你开始时得到了这份工作，在此之前你当了多年单口喜剧演员。那次转变是怎样的？
Did you know at that moment you were saying, goodbye to your stand-up career and that you were going in different direction? Yeah. In my day, those days, a long time ago, was much easier to know what you were gonna do and know how to get there. And so I knew that if I wanted to get a television show,
你当时就知道你要对你的单口喜剧生涯说再见，并且你要走一条不同的方向吗？对。在我的时代，那些日子，很久以前，更容易知道你要做什么以及如何到达那里。所以我知道如果我想做一档电视节目，
I had to go to California and start doing stand-up. And then you get on the tonight show, then if you're lucky other things happen. And that's exactly what happened for me. Where did doing the weather in Indianapolis fit into that plan? That was my nascent television career. So that was the door that was open happened to be the weather door? Yes. Yes. Yes.
我必须去加州开始做单口喜剧。然后你上了《今夜秀》，如果幸运的话，其他事情就会发生。而这正是我身上发生的事情。在印第安纳波利斯播天气预报是怎么融入那个计划的？那是我的萌芽期电视生涯。所以那是敞开的门，刚好是天气之门？是的。是的。是的。
And did you enjoy that? I just enjoyed, first of all, not a meteorologist. Did not know anything about the weather. Still really don't. But it was, you know, I was like 20 years old and they put me on TV. So that's kind of what I enjoyed. And then I knew that this is what I wanted to do with my life,
你喜欢那样吗？我只是喜欢，首先，我不是气象学家。对天气一无所知。现在其实也一样。但你知道，我当时大概20岁，他们把我弄上电视。所以这差不多就是我喜欢的地方。然后我知道这就是我想用我的一生去做的，
not this necessarily. But nobody wants to do this. It's only about 15 minutes more. Yeah. You're all. And so then I went to California and I got this show and we moved to New York. And it was like Sean said, it was 90 minutes live.
不一定是这个。但没有人想做这个。大概只要再多15分钟。对。你们所有人。然后我就去了加州，得到了这个节目，我们搬到了纽约。就像肖恩说的，那是90分钟的直播。
And within a month, the NBC daytime television that were collapsed. And affiliates were running. They were selling their stations. They were burning things. Insurance people were investigating all because of me and my friends. And I don't know how you guys felt about your on-trader showbiz, but you've made a life of it when you were trying to. No, no, but I mean, along you were trying to. I'm trying to. No, no, but I mean, along, you were born to it. Yes, yeah.
不到一个月的时间，NBC的白天电视节目就崩溃了。附属机构在逃跑。他们在卖掉他们的电台。他们在烧东西。保险人员都在调查，全都是因为我和我的朋友们。我不知道你们对自己的娱乐圈生涯感觉如何，但当你在尝试时，你已经为此过上了生活。不，不，我的意思是，长期以来你在尝试。我在尝试。不，不，我的意思是，长久以来，你生来就是吃这碗饭的。是的，是的。
How old were you, sir, Jason? How old were your first professional engagement in show business? Little house on the prairie. Little house. Does that, that he knows that? He knows that. Does that, how does that feel, Jason?
先生，杰森，你当时多大？你在娱乐圈的第一次专业演出多大？《草原小屋》。《草原小屋》。那，这个他知道？他知道这个。那，那感觉怎么样，杰森？
I'm, it's going to take me a while to get over that. I remember seeing you on a couple of silver spoons. Oh yeah. Yeah. Dave, did you think that you were gonna do when you moved out to California as a standup? Did you think that you have aspirations to be an actor, to do a sitcom?
我，我得花点时间才能缓过来。我记得在几集《银匙》里看过你。哦，是的。是的。戴夫，当你作为单口喜剧演员搬到加州时，你认为你会做什么？你认为你有志于成为一名演员，去拍情景喜剧吗？
Was that something that was, no. What I wanted to do was. Who wants to do those? You know. Ha ha ha ha. Me? No. No, what I wanted to do was... Who wants to do those? It's me. Me? No. No, I just knew I wanted a Johnny Carson's job. Right, right. So you always knew that. If we've not his job, a job like that.
那是你想过的吗，不。我想做的是。谁想做那些？你知道的。哈哈哈哈哈。我？不。不，我想做的是……谁想做那些？是我。我？不。不，我只知道我想要约翰尼·卡森的工作。对，对。所以你一直都知道。就算不是他的工作，也是类似的工作。
Yeah, because I can't do it all the time. We talk about that a lot, like if you, when you're that young knowing exactly what you wanna do, that your odds go up that you will achieve that, because you're so focused on a goal, isn't that? But what made you, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, Johnny was so good at so many things, and one of them was his kindness and conservative sort of approach to certain things. He was very unthreatening. It's actually a different, it's actually a different,
对，因为我不能一直做。我们经常谈论这个，如果你，当你那么年轻就知道自己想做什么，你成功的几率就会上升，因为你太专注于一个目标了，不是吗？但什么让你，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以，所以有几个人离开。我们走吧，卡罗尔。这是你的第一次，艾伦。关于珠穆朗玛峰，有一种神奇的吸引力吸引着我。你对珠穆朗玛峰有什么吸引力吗？嗯，我对珠穆朗玛峰了解很多，因为我看了两打关于攀登珠穆朗玛峰的电影
it was very unthreatening in the best way. Now, your sense of humor has got this incredibly awesome hilarious edge sarcasm, dryness to it, which is near and dear to my heart. Your sense of humor has got this incredibly awesome hilarious edge sarcasm, dryness to it, which is near and dear to my heart. What made you confident that you would be able to make a career of that without America being afraid of it? He's trying to say, why did you think you could be in showbiz? Oh, thank you.
这种感觉毫无压迫感，而且恰到好处。现在，你的幽默感有一种非常棒、令人捧腹的尖锐感、讽刺感和冷幽默，这正合我意。你的幽默感有一种非常棒、令人捧腹的尖锐感、讽刺感和冷幽默，这正合我意。是什么让你确信自己能以此为生，而美国人又不会为此感到害怕？他其实是想问，为什么你觉得你可以进娱乐圈？哦，谢谢你。
Oh. Well, I was, I had horrible grades in school. I knew I wasn't going anywhere academically, and I had a speech class, my sophomore year in high school, where the first thing you had to do in speech class, stand up and give us an impromptu, five minute introductory speech. I did that, and when I sat down, I realized, oh, I know exactly what I want to do. So, the schooling of it made no difference, oh, I know exactly what I want to do. So the schooling of it made no difference, and then later I figured out a way to do that.
哦。好吧，我在学校里的成绩一塌糊涂。我知道自己在学术上没有什么前途，但在我高二的时候，我有一门演讲课，课上的第一项任务就是站起来做一个五分钟的即兴自我介绍演讲。我完成了，当我坐下时，我意识到，哦，我知道自己到底想做什么了。所以，接受正规教育与否并没有什么区别，哦，我知道自己到底想做什么了。所以接受正规教育与否并没有什么区别，后来我想出了一种实现它的方法。
So as you point out, a rare comment on your part. Yep. He does listen to the show. It's amazing. It's so flattering. And I feel bad for a lot of people who just don't know what they want to do, right? Because if you do know that, it's a true gift. Yeah, I agree. But that you were able to take that sense of humor and you do your show and somebody
正如你所指出的，这是你难得发表的评论。没错。他确实听这个节目。太神奇了。这真是过奖了。我为许多不知道自己想做什么的人感到难过，对吧？因为如果你确实知道，那真是天赋异禀。是的，我同意。但你能把这种幽默感带到你的节目中，而且当有人
sits down in that guest chair and they're not being a good guest. And I'll bet that incredibly sharp, caustic sort of sense of humor in the best sense of the word starts to fire and you have to start the self-edit of, how nasty can I be to this person? Yeah, because they deserve it. And America that's watching knows they deserve it, but you gotta kind of calibrate it.
坐在那个嘉宾椅上，却表现得不像个好嘉宾时。我敢打赌，你那种极其犀利、尖酸刻薄却又恰到好处的幽默感就要被点燃了，你不得不开始自我审查：我对这个人能刻薄到什么程度？是的，因为他们罪有应得。正在观看节目的美国观众也知道他们罪有应得，但你必须把握好分寸。
What is that process? Well, yeah, really quick, one of the funniest examples of that in history is the walking phoenix when you just couldn't get anything out of them. And I think your line was, I think your line was, I think your line was, I think your line was, well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight.
这个过程是怎样的？好吧，说真的，历史上最有趣的例子之一就是华金·菲尼克斯那次，你简直从他嘴里套不出半句话。我想你的台词是，我想你的台词是，我想你的台词是，我想你的台词是，好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。
I think you were right. I think your line was, I think your line was, well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. I think you were right. Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight.
我想你是对的。我想你的台词是，我想你的台词是，好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。我想你是对的。好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。
Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. Well, I'm sorry, you couldn't make it tonight. We'll be right back. Since his death in 2009, the world has struggled with how Michael Jackson should be remembered, as the King of Pop or as a monster. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator. Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after.
好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。好吧，很遗憾，你今晚没能来。我们马上回来。自从迈克尔·杰克逊在2009年去世以来，世人一直在争论该如何纪念他：是将他视为流行音乐之王，还是一个恶魔。我是莱昂·内法克，《Fiasco》的主持人兼《Slow Burn》的共同创作者。我是杰伊·斯穆斯，一位嘻哈记者和文化评论员。迈克尔·杰克逊在1993年首次被指控猥亵儿童。我们的新播客《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》讲述了这一切发生之前和之后的故事。
Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancelable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store. Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man
在整个播客中，我们探讨了是什么让迈克尔·杰克逊似乎永远不会被“取消”。我们也深入探讨了当我们听到杂货店里播放《比利·吉恩》时，我们许多人内心的复杂情感。通过对那些亲历这一事件的人们进行的数十次原创采访，《三思》试图调和我们对迈克尔·杰克逊这位男士的矛盾情感，
with our deep-seated love of his art. Listen to think twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series ad-free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music app. And now back to the show. And then the opposite would be true. The opposite would be, he did the nicest thing for me once.
以及我们对他的艺术的骨子里的热爱。请在各大播客平台收听《三思：迈克尔·杰克逊》，或者您也可以在 Audible 或 Amazon Music 应用程序上免广告畅听整季节目。现在，让我们回到节目中。接下来情况则完全相反。相反的情况是，他曾经为我做过一件最棒的事。
We're doing the interview and I said something that was unkind to someone in my family. I thought it was funny and I could say because they were in my family and the audience roared with laughter. We go to commercial and then Dave leans over and he goes, so what we're going to do is I'm going to reintroduce you. You're going to come out and we're going gonna cut that career-cancelling comment you just made. And I remember this, sir. And I said, what do you talk, which part? He goes, you remember when you called such and such and such and such, and I was like,
我们在做采访时，我说了一些对不起我家里人的话。我觉得这挺有趣的，而且因为他们是我的家人，所以我可以说，观众们哄堂大笑。我们进入广告时间，然后戴夫靠过来对我说，我们接下来要做的就是，我要重新介绍你出场。你将重新走出来，我们将剪掉你刚才说的那句会毁了你职业生涯的话。我还记得这件事，先生。我说，你在说什么，哪部分？他说，你还记得当你称呼某某某某为……的时候，我当时想，
but they love that. He goes, you're not gonna love it. We're gonna redo the top. And I came back, he re-entrusted me. I came back, we reshot the whole big. How many times have you done that? That was such a nice thing you did for me. Not...
但他们很喜欢那样。他说，你不会喜欢的。我们要重录开头部分。然后我回来了，他重新介绍了我。我回来了，我们把整段都重拍了。你做过多少次这种事？你为我做的事太好了。不……
That was the only time you ever did. Never did it, didn't have to do it much. I had to do it quite a lot with myself. Yeah, really? Yeah, yeah, really. I was gonna ask you, do you remember those vividly? The top... Do you have the top 10?
那是你唯一一次这么做。从来没做过，不需要经常这样做。我自己倒是要经常这样做。是吗，真的吗？对，真的，真的。我本来想问你，你对那些还记忆犹新吗？开头……你有前10名吗？
No. Why, I wish... I-I-I'm not asking you. Sure. Yeah, we live in fun times. But I remember this was a thing, Sarah Palin. Near and dear. Near and dear.
没有。为什么，我希望……我—我—我不是在问你。当然。是的，我们生活在一个有趣的时代。但我记得曾有过这么一出，萨拉·佩林。亲密无间。亲密无间。
Remind me. Remind me. This was a joke I told Sarah Palin and one of her daughters had been at Yankee Stadium. Already funny. She had two daughters at the time. I don't know the state of the family now, but at the time I think there were two. And there was a younger one and an older one. I assumed that it had been the older of the two. It was a matter of the... I'm loving it.
提醒我一下。提醒我一下。这是我讲给萨拉·佩林的一个笑话，她的一个女儿当时去过洋基体育场。这本身就很有趣。她当时有两个女儿。我不知道现在这家人怎么样了，但当时我想是有两个。有一个小一点的，还有一个大一点的。我以为那是两个女儿中较大的那个。这是关于……我喜欢这样。
I'm loving it every more, so I love it. Keep going. So I assumed it was the older daughter. And the joke was some clumsy suggestion that Alex Rodriguez had made a move on the daughter. Later, I find out to my embarrassment that it was, in fact, the younger daughter, this joke entirely inappropriate.
我越来越喜欢了，所以我很喜欢。继续说。所以我以为那是大女儿。这个笑话带有一种笨拙的暗示，说亚历克斯·罗德里格斯对那个女儿采取了行动。后来，令我尴尬的是，我发现事实上那是小女儿，这个笑话完全不合时宜。
So now I... Oh, I remember that. So she was south of 18. I don't know her age. I just know that I had made a mistake. So I thought long and hard, and we had meetings on it, and we crafted an apology to Sarah Palin and her family and to everyone at Yankee Stadium.
所以现在我……哦，我记起来了。所以她还未满18岁。我不知道她的年龄。我只知道我犯了个错误。所以我进行了长时间的深思熟虑，我们为此开了会，并精心起草了一份致萨拉·佩林及其家人以及洋基体育场所有人的道歉声明。
And did they respond? Well, here's what happened. I now, it's, I do the opening and you can just feel the lead and sense of dread in the theater because I'm about to pour my guts out, apologizing, and it deserved an apology. It was stupid, ignorant, more than stupid. Which is better, by the way. Ignorant.
他们回应了吗？嗯，事情是这样的。现在，事情是这样的，我做了开场白，你在剧院里就能感受到那种沉重感和恐惧感，因为我要敞开心扉，诚恳道歉，而且这确实值得道歉。这太愚蠢了，无知，比愚蠢还过分。顺便问一句，哪个更好？无知。
Ignorant? Yeah. So I went through the, I'm way. Ignorant. Ignorant, yeah. So I went through the, I'm so sorry, and I didn't mean to, and please forgive me, Sarah, and your beautiful daughter, Tiffany. And we go to commercial and they come back, and they said, her name is Sean. LAUGHTER
无知？是的。所以我经历了那种，我很……无知。无知，是的。所以我经历了那种，我非常抱歉，我不是故意的，请原谅我，萨拉，还有你美丽的女儿蒂凡尼。然后我们进入广告，他们回来后说，她的名字叫肖恩。笑声
LAUGHTER CHEERING Did you tell you had a apology for the apology? Yeah, then we had to do the whole thing again, which was now, you know, nobody wants to sit through the nearly tearful apology twice. Yeah, sure. So you have the luxury of being a slight tape delay where you can go back, you can catch something like that. How do you then?
笑声欢呼声你是不是说过你还要为这个道歉再道一次歉？是的，然后我们不得不把整套流程再重来一遍，现在呢，你知道的，没有人愿意听两次几乎饱含泪水的道歉。是的，当然。所以你有轻微延迟录播的优势，你可以回看，你可以抓住类似这样的情况。那你接下来怎么做？
Have you ever done that? I did Conan once, and I was driving when he was doing after the Tonight Show, the Conan Show, and I was driving back. We had done a bit in the opening, and I thought, boy, I'm gonna spend a lot of time running an apology in the right column of the Huffington Post next week about why this joke.
你做过这种事吗？我有一次上柯南的节目，当时我在开车，那是他在主持完《今夜秀》之后主持《柯南秀》的时候，我在开车回去的路上。我们在开场时演了一段，我想，天哪，下周我得花很多时间在《赫芬顿邮报》的专栏里发一篇道歉信，解释为什么会有这个笑话。
And so I called and I just said, can you just take it out? They did. And it was a great joke. Did you get requests? Did you get requests like that from guests that would go out? Oh, yeah. In those days, you would hear about it
所以我打了电话，直接说，你们能把它删掉吗？他们照做了。而且那是个很棒的笑话。你收到过这样的请求吗？你会收到嘉宾提出这种要求，要求删掉播出的内容吗？哦，是的。在那个年代，你会在
the next week from their publicist. Sure. Or you would try to make the booking again six months later, you would hear about it from the publicist. I said this one thing that we had to get cut out which we'll cut out of this too is Yeah, I was just like a flip. They might be recording and they won't cut it So Now what is the joke? Can you tell the joke? All right, if you don't tell anyone You know go Sean, Sean. By the way, this was, I'm guessing this was 10 years ago, too.
第二周从他们的公关那里听到这事。当然。或者当你六个月后试图再次预定他们上节目时，你会从公关那里听到这事。我说了这么一件事，我们得把它剪掉，这期节目里我们也会把它剪掉……是的，我刚才就像是一时口快。他们可能在录音，然后他们不会剪掉它，所以……现在，笑话是什么？你能讲讲这个笑话吗？好吧，如果你不告诉别人的话……你知道的，去吧，肖恩，肖恩。顺便说一句，我猜这大概是10年 以前的事了。
And it was just a joke that was, again, I thought a great joke. By the way, if he gets canceled, Dave, will you fill in for Will? Sure. No. He doesn't own a laptop. Oh. So that's the requirement of the game. It's just don't own a laptop. Oh. So that's the requirement of the game. It's just don'ting a laptop.
这只是个笑话，再次说明，我当时觉得是个绝妙的笑话。顺便说一句，如果他被封杀的话，戴夫，你会代替威尔吗？当然不。他连笔记本电脑都没有。哦。所以这就是这个游戏的规则。只要没有笔记本电脑就行。哦。所以这就是这个游戏的规则。只要没有笔记本电脑就行。
What were you doing in London, by the way? I was writing. I was doing a rewrite on a script. Oh. I'm filled with my, with Chappy. I don't know if people remember Chappy. I remember the name from the show. Yeah.
顺便问一下，你在伦敦做什么？我在写作。我在重写一个剧本。哦。我和查比在一起。我不知道人们是否还记得查比。我从节目中记得这个名字。是的。
My writing partner. So we were doing a... Dave, you just missed kind of, I mean, we just touched on it. You kind of missed that cancel culture. Just at the end, yes, it was happening, but not at the rate it. You Dave, you just missed kind of, I mean, we just touched on it. You kind of missed that cancel culture. Just at the end, yes, it was happening, but not at the rate it's happening now, right? That's all.
我的写作搭档。所以我们在做……戴夫，你刚才差不多错过了，我的意思是，我们刚刚触及了这个话题。你差不多错过了那种“取消文化”。就在最后阶段，是的，它正在发生，但没有像现在这样的速度……戴夫，你刚才差不多错过了，我的意思是，我们刚刚触及了这个话题。你差不多错过了那种“取消文化”。就在最后阶段，是的，它正在发生，但没有像现在这样的速度发展，对吧？就是这样。
Yeah, do you think the writing, no, no. Do you think that you're writing process? Good point. Good point. Good point. Careful with the good point. But, slowly. And then he said, good point.
是的，你觉得写作……不，不。你觉得你和你的团队每天晚上的写作过程，在当今的文化氛围下会有所不同吗？是的，毫无疑问。绝对会。我个人的感觉是，
Do you think that you're writing process with your staff each night would have been different in today's culture? Yes, yeah. Without question. Absolutely. And my personal feeling about this is, Careful. And you hear quite a lot of discussion about,
小心。你会听到很多关于以下的讨论，
oh, are we too woke? Or is it, are we cancelling too quickly? Are we overcorrecting? And I feel like, you know, let's overcorrect and see what happens. They all create, it's just, the worst that happens is, oh, we've overcorrected. And then it'll re-correct. But there are many, many things a person needs
哦，我们是不是太“觉醒”了？或者说，我们是不是取消得太快了？我们是不是矫枉过正了？我觉得，你知道的，让我们矫枉过正看看会发生什么。它们都会产生影响，最坏的情况也就是，哦，我们矫枉过正了。然后它会自我纠正。但一个人需要有很多很多的事情
to be smart and sensitive about that, here to four, perhaps we were not. Two of my favorite guests that you had on your show a lot. One was your first guest and your last guest, Bill Murray. And the other one was the incredible. And I was fortunate to know a tiny bit, Charles Groden. Can you talk a little bit about those two guys? Well, Bill Murray, I a put you in business.
去保持聪明和敏感，而在此之前，也许我们并没有做到。你在节目中经常邀请的两位我最喜欢的嘉宾。一位是你的第一位嘉宾和最后一位嘉宾，比尔·默瑞。另一位是令人难以置信的……我有幸稍微了解一点的查尔斯·格罗丁。你能稍微谈谈这两个人吗？嗯，比尔·默瑞，我……让你开张了。
He was in Boston last night. I don't know why he didn't use him. No. He's playing golf at the beach. Oh, playing golf, I'm sorry. Okay, I got some bad info. We couldn't make Bill deal last night. No, Bill put you in business.
他昨晚在波士顿。我不知道为什么他没用他。不。他在海滩打高尔夫球。哦，打高尔夫球，对不起。好吧，我得到了错误的信息。我们昨晚没能和比尔达成交易。不，比尔让你开张了。
And he did it on our first show at 10-30, I think, or, no, 12-30, whenever I was deal last night. Bill put you in business and he did it on our first show at 10, 30 I think, or no, 12, 30, whenever. Depending on time zone. And then he came on the failed morning show. Bill came on and Steve Martin came on the failed morning show also. And it was people like this that gave us a lifeline because they were so and still are beloved and generous.
他在我们的第一期节目上做到了，大概是10点30分，或者，不，12点30分，无论我……昨晚的交易。比尔让你开张了，他在我们的第一期节目上做到了，大概是10点30分，或者，不，12点30分，无论……这取决于时区。然后他上了那个失败的早间秀。比尔来了，史蒂夫·马丁也上了那个失败的早间秀。正是这样的人给了我们一线生机，因为他们过去是、现在也依然是备受喜爱且慷慨大方的人。
And to come on, these two guys, and just a miserable little smoking rag of snot. Sure. Yeah. Was something like that? That's what I was talking about them? No, no, I'm talking about my show. I'm not sure.
这两家伙肯上节目，而当时这只是一块悲惨的、冒烟的鼻涕抹布。当然。是的。是这样的吗？我当时是在说他们吗？不，不，我是在说我的节目。我不确定。
Not my show. No, it was great. And so in every case, having Bill on the first show was lovely. And did it make you feel like you're making us feel right now like a validation beyond your wildest expectations? We're real happy you're here. I'm happy to be here.
不是我的节目。不，这很棒。所以在每种情况下，让比尔上第一期节目都是一件可爱的事。这有没有让你觉得，正如你现在让我们感觉到的那样，有一种超乎你最疯狂想象的肯定？我们很高兴你能来。我也很高兴能来到这里。
I loved Bill then, and I love Bill now. And he's never, he was always on the show. And he was always generous with his friendship and his talent for me in the show. I think it's such a brilliantly hilarious guy, another guy that, of course, we all, they're... Easily hilarious. That's never worked hard.
我过去喜欢比尔，现在也喜欢比尔。他从未缺席，他总是上节目。而且对于我和节目来说，他总是慷慨地奉献他的友谊和才华。我认为他是一个才华横溢、极其搞笑的人，另一个当然也是我们所有人都……轻松搞笑。那可从来没那么努力过。
Well, there are certain people we always, I was describing that they have no choice in the matter. Bill has no choice but to be funny. Will Farrell, whom we had on our first night in DC, has no choice but to be funny. Marty Short, maybe the funniest person in the planet, has no choice in the matter. He wakes up and that's the way, that's his disposition. But I was also going to say, in Jason brought up, we'd been talking about Charles Grote, and Jason did a film with him, and he was an incredibly funny guy,
嗯，有些人我们总是……我刚才在形容他们对此别无选择。比尔除了搞笑别无选择。我们在华盛顿特区第一晚请到的威尔·法瑞尔，除了搞笑别无选择。马蒂·肖特，可能是地球上最搞笑的人，对此别无选择。他一醒来就是那个状态，那是他的天性。但我还想说，正如杰森提起的，我们一直在讨论查尔斯·格罗丁，杰森和他合作过一部电影，他是个极其搞笑的人，
an incredibly good actor, and what I always loved about his appearances on your show is he came in with a point of view. So he had a story, which was often that he was not pleased about being on the show. Yeah, not to be there. And it's somehow immediately even you saying, welcome to the show, he was really put off by that. That's right.
也是个极其优秀的演员，我一直很喜欢他在你的节目中表现的一点是，他带着鲜明的观点出场。所以他有一个故事，通常是关于他对上节目感到不高兴。是的，不想待在那儿。不知何故，甚至在你刚说“欢迎来到节目”时，他就对这句话非常反感。没错。
And did that kind of, he set up a parameters of a game for the two of you? Yeah, it was delightful, but that model, that template comes from his appearances on the tonight show at Johnny Carson. And he would go on with Carson, and his point of view with Carson was, you don't know anything. You're wealthy. You don't go anywhere. You have people do everything
这是否有点像，他为你俩设定了某种游戏规则？是的，这太有趣了，但那个模式、那个模板源自他当年在约翰尼·卡森的《今夜秀》上的表现。他会去上卡森的节目，他对卡森的观点是：你什么都不知道。你很有钱。你哪儿也不去。你让别人为你做一切
for you. And then he would start with Johnny. For example, what's a quarter-milk cost? You don't know what a quarter-milk cost. And he would just run Johnny around the theater like that. And the feeling was that that there's bad but no they both loved it and it was the same dynamic that he brought to our show that must have been one of those examples of a guest who when they came on they made the show better and that's so grateful that he'd been there that's that's exactly right and you mentioned Marty short oh my goodness this guy Marty Marty you're right can't help but be fun.
事情。然后他就会开始质问约翰尼。例如，一杯四分之一加仑的牛奶多少钱？你根本不知道四分之一加仑的牛奶多少钱。他就会这样把约翰尼在剧院里耍得团团转。那种感觉是，虽然有点糟糕，但他们都很喜欢，而且这和他在我们的节目中带来的是同一种化学反应，那一定是那些让节目变得更好的嘉宾的例子之一，我们太感激他曾来过那里了，完全是这样，你提到了马蒂·肖特，哦天哪，这家伙，马蒂，马蒂，你说得对，就是忍不住要搞笑。
Can't help and I love because he does it all these ways and old bit, but he'll walk into Sean's house and go, I can't believe you live here. I mean, I've seen your work. I can't believe. Yeah. You know, just true. That's all he does.
情不自禁，我喜欢他这样做是因为他有很多种方式，还有老把戏，但他会走进肖恩的家里说，我简直不敢相信你住在这种地方。我的意思是，我看过你的作品。我简直不敢相信。是的。你知道的，就是那么真实。他就会这样。
That's all he does. By the way, by the way, every time, every time I laugh. Of course. Yeah. Of course, brilliant. Yeah, brilliant. laugh. Of course. Yeah. Of course. Brilliant. Yeah, I am brilliant. When are you Canadian? Yeah, very Canadian.
他就会这样。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，每次，每次我都大笑。当然。是的。当然，太精彩了。是的，太精彩了。大笑。当然。是的。当然。太精彩了。是的，我很精彩。你什么时候成加拿大人了？是的，非常加拿大。
Yeah, we've just seen devil out of Canadians here tonight. Yeah, he's... Listen, I don't want to take any more of your time. You're just an incredible guy. I mean, no, listen, you got to... 58 minutes into this. You don't want to take any more of my time. I... Listen, you know, you got a minute into this you don't want to take any more of my time
是的，我们今晚在这里刚见识了一群加拿大人。是的，他……听着，我不想再占用你的时间了。你真是个了不起的人。我的意思是，不，听着，你得……这都快58分钟了。你不想再占用我的时间。我……听着，你知道的，这都过去一分钟了，你不想再占用我的时间
I I just can't tell you just be personally. I don't want to speak for these two. This is a Peak in my life and will be hard to be top. I thank you so much Way too kind. No, seriously. I concur. Wait, I think the first time I did your show, I think it was the first time that my parents really believed that I was in show business. Yes. And it's been an absolute thrill to get to know you.
我……我简直无法表达，就我个人而言。我可不想代表这两位。这是我人生中的一个巅峰，很难再超越了。非常感谢你。太客气了。不，说真的。我附议。等等，我想我第一次上你的节目时，那大概是我父母真正相信我在娱乐圈发展的第一次。是的。能有机会了解你，绝对是一场令人兴奋的经历。
Well, everyone, Sean, did I leave you out? Is there something loving to say about me. No, I do. And it's a longer reach, but go ahead. Yes. No, I... You should have your own talk show. OK, well, by the way, Sean... No, I just want to say...
好吧，各位，肖恩，我是把你漏掉了吗？关于我，有什么充满爱意的话要说吗？不，我有。这是一个更宏大的愿景，但请继续。是的。不，我……你应该有自己的脱口秀。好吧，顺便说一句，肖恩……不，我只是想说……
I want to say... You were going to have a talk show. Who knows what's happening? So listen. Oh, no, wait a minute. You can't keep something like that from these guys. From all these guys. There's a veil. They're not going to say anything. No, I echo what Will said about, yeah, no, about,
我想说……你本来要主持一个脱口秀。谁知道现在怎么样了？所以听着。哦，不对，等等。你对这些人可瞒不住这种事。对所有这些人。这里有一层面纱。他们什么都不会说。不，我赞同威尔刚才说的，关于，是的，不，关于，
and I know you've heard, I know your reaction whenever there's praise that you know, it's always, I get who you are, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. You know, I'm rolling your eyes. No, but I really want to, because I'm never going to have blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah Well, you came back again and again and you always had me back and it was such a every time was like was just like now I just can't believe I'm in your presence because I'm very well. You're so kind Thank you, yeah, yeah, but you didn't you guys weren't guests on the show by accident No, I was I was yeah Somebody can't No, I would love, I would. He wears that, yeah. Somebody chance, like the last minute. That's always good to have.
我知道你听过，我也知道每当有人赞美你时，你的反应总是“我懂你是谁，啦啦啦啦啦”。你知道的，我在翻白眼。不，但我真的很想说，因为我再也不会……好吧，你一次又一次地回来，总是支持我，每一次都让我觉得……现在我简直不敢相信我就在你的面前，因为我很……好吧，你太好了，谢谢你，对，对，但你们上节目可不是偶然的。不，我是……不，我……有人不……不，我很乐意，我会的。他穿着那件，对。有人碰巧，就像最后一分钟那样。能有这样的人真好。
I will say, there was about five or six years where I was lucky enough to be doing a couple of talk shows and I kept hearing from them. I say, maybe try to get on David. No, he doesn't, not done like kids or, or doesn't want kids on. No, no, didn't say that. Well, it like, I had to...
我要说的是，大概有五六年时间，我很幸运能做几个脱口秀节目，而且我一直听到他们说。我说，也许试着上大卫的节目。不，他不……不让小孩上，或者……不想让小孩上。不，不，没那么说。好吧，就像，我不得不……
Wow, yeah. Yeah. If you're too young, no, no, no, I didn't say that. Like I had to... Wow, yeah. Yeah. If you're too young, it's like, but so when finally, it was the yes it was like, when you were old enough to be on the show. Yes. Wait, I'm gonna really embarrass you last thing. This is gonna embarrass the show you.
哇，对。对。如果你太年轻，不，不，不，我没那么说。就像我不得不……哇，对。对。如果你太年轻，就像……但是当终于得到肯定的答复时，就像你到了可以上节目的年龄。对。等等，我要让你难堪了，最后一件事。这会让你觉得尴尬。
You know, you did something. You did something. You had a lot of fun. More fun thing on such a high note. No, I know, you did something. You did something. You had, you had, we were on. We were on. No, I know. I said, you're gonna take it further. You were on Alec Baldwin's podcast a long time ago, and you said during the interview, you said,
你知道的，你做了一件事。你做了一件事。你玩得很开心。以非常棒的方式结束。不，我知道，你做了一件事。你做了一件事。你……我们上过。我们上过。不，我知道。我说，你会把它推得更远。很久以前你上过亚历克·鲍德温的播客，你在采访中说，你说过……
we just had Sean Hayes, who was doing a show called, I don't know, High Ho promises across the street. And, and you said, God was he funny. He's one of the funniest people, and I saved that clip, and it's still on my phone. Really, yes. And so I will say this. Now I'm going to admit something. I moved into, still not gay.
我们刚刚请到了肖恩·海斯，他在街对面做一个叫什么来着《政界小丑》的节目。而且，你曾说过，天哪，他真搞笑。他是最搞笑的人之一，我把那个片段保存下来了，现在还在我的手机里。真的，是的。所以我要这么说。现在我要承认一件事。我搬进了……依然不是同性恋。
No. What's happening? I moved into a new house, and oh. And I had not gay. No. I, I, I, what's happening? I moved into a new house and oh. Uh, and, and I had a bunch, I had a, at, at a, at a bunch of photos that were on my laptop and I, and I, and I, and I put them in, and it created a file to print some photos and a lot of photos of the kids, et cetera, uh, to put up outside the boys' rooms. And one of them that I put up to be printed was a photo of, I guess somebody sent me from your show, and I was sitting on the chair just like that
不。怎么回事？我搬进了一间新房子，哦。而且我……依然不是同性恋。不。我，我，我，怎么回事？我搬进了一间新房子，哦。呃，而且，而且我有一堆，我有一……在，在，在……有一堆照片在我的笔记本电脑上，我，我，我，我把它们存进去，创建了一个文件夹来冲洗一些照片，有很多孩子们的照片等等，呃，打算挂在男孩们房间的外面。我挂出来打算冲洗的照片之一是，我猜有人从你的节目发给我的照片，我当时就那样坐在椅子上
with we did at the top, where I was mimicking, smoking. And the thrill to me was that you, I was doing this bit and you were laughing. And it is figures prominently in my hall amongst with my family and you. Yeah. This is a true story. If my boys were here, they would attest to this. Because it was such a monumental moment in my life.
我们在顶端做的那种，我模仿吸烟。让我激动的是，你……我在做这个包袱，而你在笑。这幅画在我的大厅里占据了显眼的位置，和我的家人还有你在一起。是的。这是一个真实的故事。如果我的男孩们在这里，他们会作证的。因为这对我的人生来说是一个极其重要的时刻。
So thank you, and I thank you. Thank you. There's some pathology behind that. Yeah. How old are your kids? I have three boys. I have a 13-year-old Archie, and I have an 11-year-old able, and I have a 20-month-old, oh, Denny. Very nice. Very good for you. Thank you.
所以谢谢你，我谢谢你。谢谢。这背后有一些心理问题。Yeah。你的孩子多大了？我有三个男孩。我有一个13岁的阿奇，我有一个11岁的阿贝尔，我还有一个20个月大的，哦，丹尼。非常不错。对你很好。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. And you? All of this, I'm not sure their names, but I think it's fifth. He's been making Ozark for the last six years, so... Oh, yeah. Yeah. We love Ozark. You know, Thank you. He's become a very successful, not just actor, and we all love him.
谢谢。谢谢。你呢？所有这些，我不太记得他们的名字，但我想是第五个。他过去六年一直在拍《黑钱胜地》，所以……哦，对。对。我们很喜欢《黑钱胜地》。你知道，谢谢。他已经成为一个非常成功的，不仅是演员，我们都很喜欢他。
He's become a really successful and incredibly talented director. And, no, it's true. That's just a very successful one. No, you are a successful one. You're talking about showbiz. It needs to be talked. Yeah, you started as a kid on, and I give you a lot of shit, but you started as a kid on, on Little House in the Pra of shit, but you started as a kid on Little House in the Prairie,
他已经成为一个真正成功且极具才华的导演。不，这是真的。这只是一个非常成功的。不，你是一个成功的人。你在说娱乐圈。这需要被谈论。是的，你小时候就开始演，我虽然总开玩笑，但你小时候就在《草原小屋》里……
and now you become a really successful and very talented director. Yes, you're a nice man. You know what's interesting about it? Show business is a meat grinder, and to begin when you're a child is one thing, to begin when you're a child, and then grow and evolve into a continuing success
而现在你已经成为一个真正成功且非常有才华的导演。是的，你是个好人。你知道这其中有趣的地方吗？娱乐圈是个绞肉机，从小开始是一回事，从小开始，然后成长并演变成持续的成功
in other and every area of show business. Yeah. Virtually impossible. Yes, for sure. Well, Sean, you and OPE is about the only... I'm going to read your Wikipedia page. Thank you. Well, it's easy when you have a north star
在娱乐圈的其他和各个领域。是的。几乎是不可能的。是的，肯定的。嗯，肖恩，你和……几乎是唯一……我要读一下你的维基百科页面。谢谢。嗯，当你拥有一个像你自己这样不可思议的北极星时，这很容易
of incredibleness like yourself, sir. Let's please all thank the one and only big letterman Thank you very much Thank you very much Always a pleasure my friend. Thank you. Now. I'm going out here Thank you Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. There's a lot of fun. I appreciate that. Thank you Jason. Thank you. I mean, I mean, so crazy.
先生。让我们一起感谢独一无二的伟大大卫·莱特曼。非常感谢。非常感谢。我的朋友，随时欢迎。谢谢。现在。我要出去了。谢谢。非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。这太有趣了。我很感激。谢谢杰森。谢谢。我是说，我是说，太疯狂了。
You guys got Dave Letterman. Yeah. I, uh... This is, I'm gonna get a lot of, I'm gonna get a lot of shit for this, but I legitimately just telling him that story and then him looking at the face as I'm telling that I almost started to cry. I saw you say I saw him start to cry. I did will he's really so. Yeah same I was like should I tell him this and I'm going to break down it's gonna be embarrassing.
你们把大卫·莱特曼请来了。Yeah。我，呃……这会……我会因此挨不少骂，但我跟他说这个故事时是真心的，当我在讲这个故事看着他的脸时，我差点哭出来。我看到你说我看到他开始哭了。我真的……他也一样，我想：我是不是该告诉他这个，然后我要崩溃了，这会很尴尬。
So but you know what did you notice what he did on the way out which was really cool. He did the same thing that he did on his talk show where he goes like this and he just goes hey thanks for coming thanks for coming. Thanks for coming thanks for coming I really appreciate. You know I don't know about you guys I. I really appreciate it. I was the best. I don't know about you guys. I mean, I know you guys as a teenager, as a guy who's whatever, does matter how old I am. But growing up in the 80s, the thing to do
所以……但是你知道吗，你注意到他在离开时做了什么吗？那真的很酷。他做回了他在脱口秀节目里做过的那套动作，他一边挥手一边说：嘿，谢谢光临，谢谢光临。谢谢光临，谢谢光临，我真的很感激。你知道，我不知道你们怎么想，我。我真的很感激。我是最棒的。我不知道你们怎么想。我是说，我知道你们作为青少年，作为一个不管多大年纪的人。但在80年代长大，要做的事情
was on weeknights was to stay up late enough to watch late night with David. Before he did the late show on CBF, which was also amazing, but to do that, and so much of the things that I loved about comedy were formed from watching him. Yeah, for sure, for sure. And just so that you guys know, not that this is about us,
工作日晚上就是熬夜看大卫的《深夜秀》。在他做哥伦比亚广播公司的《晚间秀》之前，那个也棒极了，但做那个节目，我关于喜剧的很多热爱都是从看他的节目中形成的。是的，绝对的，绝对的。为了让你们知道，并不是说这是关于我们的，
because it's about all of us, but just so that you guys know. Since when is it not about us? This was an enormous thing for us. us like the fact that he said yes I mean He said he said yes to do this he said yes to do this because People listen to it. That's you guys. So thank you for doing this for us and how Thank you for doing this for us. And how would he sign off at the end of the night?
因为这是关于我们所有人的，但为了让你们知道。什么时候不是关于我们的了？这对我们来说是一件大事。我们……就像他答应了这件事，我是说，他答应做这件事，他答应做这件事，因为人们在听。那就是你们。所以谢谢你们为我们做这些，以及……谢谢你们为我们做这些。那天晚上他会怎么结尾？
No, Sean, no. What I'm just asking. Give us a second. Let it breathe. I'm just saying I can't remember how he would. Just knowing that he's still out there speeding along all those highways and byways. Thank you guys so much. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael
不，肖恩，不。我只是在问。给我们一秒钟。让它缓一缓。我只是说我不记得他是怎么……只要知道他仍然在所有的公路和小路上风驰电掣。非常感谢你们，伙计们。Smartless由罗布·阿姆朱夫、贝内特·巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里100%有机手工制作。
Granterry. Smart, last. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。